[موسيقى]
اي لاف يو
الحياه في جمهوريه اوزوكيز لقد مكست فيها
12 عاما وانا اعشق هذا المكان انه يعج
بالاشجار ويمدنا بطاقه الابداع الايجابيه
الافكار وانطباعات كلها تنطلقوا من الجو
المحيط من الناس والجيران والوسط الفني
اثنين منذ عام 2016
بس اوف
ماشيه
من مرتديل مقاهي والنوادي يعيد خلق العالم
مع اصدقائه وبما انه شاعر فهو يكتب بعذوبه
غالبيه الناس ترمي الاوراق بعد ان تعيد
خلق العالم اما هو فاحتفظ بهذه القصيده
البدائيه البديعه في النص يحق لك ان تكون
سعيدا او تعيسا تلك القصيده شكل الدستور
جمهوريه اوزوبيس وبفضل ذلك الدستور انبثقت
جمهوريه اوزوبيس
مثل باقي الدول في العالم تملك جمهوريه
الفنانين اوزوبيس دستورا خاصا بها
معلقا على احد الجدران
ويتكون الدستور من 41 بندا
ومترجم الى قرابه 25 لغه ومنها اللغه
العربيه
من ابرز البنود الغريبه لدستور جمهوريه
اوزوبيس
لكل انسان الحق في ان يعيش على جانب نهر
فيلنيا
والمقصود النهر الذي يحيط بجمهوريه
الفنانين القطه غير مجبره على ان تحب
صاحبها للكلب الحق في ان يكون كلبا
ولكل انسان الحق في ان يكون سعيدا
علم الجمهوريه عباره عن يد مثقوبه وتعني
الشفافيه وعدم الاختلاف
وتتغير الوانه
قبلها اقمت قرب ساحه تمثال الملاك زواء
ثمان سنوات اتيت الى اذكيس التي تعجبني
لانها مكان للفن كثير من الفنانين يعيشون
هنا كما تاتي اعداد من السياح للاطلاع وهو
مكان الجذاب نمتلك قصه نرويها تحاكي
الاسطوره عن جمهوريه مستقله لا تشبه غيرها
لها قوانينها وحكمتها
روس
[موسيقى]